hey what's up guys it's rob i'm back and  i'm bringing you a brand new  transforming ninja star that'll be out  soon on my channel it changes from this  cool frisbee configuration and when you  push the pieces together it changes into  an awesome three-pointed star just like  that  not only does it fly great as a frisbee  in the frisbee configuration as you can  see here but if you hold it in a certain  way it can actually curve towards you  but generally does not come back all the  way so it's not a true boomerang so be  sure to subscribe and click that  notification bell that way when i do  release it you'll be the first to know  about the triple transforming ninja star  and i'll see you guys soon